قال مسؤول ايراني للجزيره ان المؤشرات
العمليه الاولى تشير الى تورط اسرائيل في
هجوم اصفهان ولابد من متابعه التحقيق
واضاف ان الترجيحات
انطلقت من داخل ايران وعلى مقربه من
الموقع المستهدف
واوضح انه هجوم اصفهان لم يكن موفقا وان
كلام المصادر الاسرائيليه مجرد دعايه
لتعتيم على الفشل حسب قوله واشار المسؤول
الايراني
على انه هناك من يلعب بالنار وانه لا شك
لدينا اهو سيكون اول من يحترق في حال
قراري او قرر اشعال حرب اقليميه
وكانت صحيفه جورنال نقلت عن مسؤوليه
امريكيه ان اسرائيل هي من نفلت الهجوم على
المرشاه ومن جهتها نقلت وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه عن مصادر ان الهجوم حقق
اهدافه في اربعه مواقع وكانت وزاره الدفاع
الايرانيه اعلنت احباطه هجوم غامض استهدفا
مصنعا عسكريا في محافظه اصفهان تبين لاحقا
انه نفذ بثلاث طائرات مسيره صغيره واكلات
الوزاره ان المضادات الدفاعيه تصده الهجوم
وان الاضرار اقتصرت على سقف المصنع دون
الاضرار بالمعدات
وبدورها
والسياسه الخارجيه في البرلمان الايراني
للمزيد عن الموقف الايرانيه وتفاعل هذا
الهجوم في طهران معنا من هناك مدير مكتب
الجزيره عبد القادر الفائز وجديد المواقف
هل هناك مواقف اخرى صدرت بهذا الخصوص هذه
القدر
[موسيقى]
واضح عبد الصمد بان هناك حرب روايات
ومعركه روايات بين روايه ايرانيه وروايه
اسرائيليه مضاده بشكل مباشر
من وزاره الدفاع عن الايرانيه هنا في
طهران في هذا السياق ياتي كلام هذا
المسؤول الرفيع للجزيره هنا في طيران
والذي يقول بان الروايه الاسرائيليه بكل
ما حملت من مصادر سواء في البعد الصحفي او
في البعد الرسمي هي غير دقيقه وبانها تريد
التعديم بحسب المسؤول الايراني على ما
اسماء فشل هذا الهجوم على هذه هذا الموقع
العسكري في همم همم اصفهان ويقول بان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تنها بنفسها
عن هذا الموضوع لانها تدرك بان ما جرى ليس
كبيرا وفاشلا وبانه وبحسب المسؤول مره
اخرى لن يدفع طيران الى تغيير سياساتها لا
في البعد الاقليمي ولا حتى في القضايا
التي تدور على الس الدوليه في نقطه اخرى
يقول هذا المسؤول للجزيره بان المؤشرات
الاوليه تشير الى تورط اسرائيلي ما في هذا
الموضوع ولكن يتبع ذلك بانه لابد من
انتظار التحقيقات ويؤكد بان الطائرات
انطلقت من داخل ايران ماذا يعني ذلك عبد
الصمد يعني بان هناك على الارض في ايران
هناك من يدعم هذا التوجه التوجه ومتورط مع
الجهات الاسرائيليه وهذا ليس بجديد بطبيعه
الحال سواء في استهداف المنشات في ايران
او في عمليات الاختلال على الاقل خلال
الثلاث سنوات الماضيه وهذا يؤكد وجود ما
همم كنا نتحدث عنهم خلال هذه السنوات عن
معركه ظل وحروب رماديه بين ايران واسرائيل
في مساحه المنطقه او في مساحه كلى البلدين
معا في النقطه الثالثه وهي نقطه مهمه
حقيقه عندما سالناه عن طبيعه الرد
الايراني وبانه لطالما تحدثت اسرائيل ولو
بشكل غير مباشر عن عمليات في الداخل
الايراني بينما لا نسمع من ايران بانها
تقوم بالرد في المساحه العلانيه كان واضحا
بان ايران فعلت ذلك سابقا وبان اسرائيل
تدرك تماما بانها ستتلقى ردا وبحسب هذا
المسؤول بان ايران تفضل ربما الابتعاد عن
الضجيج وكثره التصريحات عندما تتحدث في
موضوع الرد على الهجمات الاسرائيليه في
نقطه اخرى ربما تبدو مهمه حقيقه عبد الصمد
لانها تاخذ بعد وسياده اقليمي يقول بان
هناك من يلعب بالنار في المنطقه وبان هذا
اللاعب بحسب المسؤول الايراني سيدفع ظريفه
وسيفع ثمنا اذا ما قرر اشعال الحرب
الاقليميه عندما نسمح هذا الكلام نفهم
بانه موجه بالدرجه الاولى الى اسرائيل
اخيرا يمكن ان نقول عبد الصمد بان هناك
انطباع ماء ربما بانه القادم ربما يشيل
بتوتر في خط العلاقه بين ايران واسرائيل
في مساحه الاقليم هل هناك دلائل مؤشرات
ربما ولكن على قاعده بان الانطباع قد يكون
اقوى ربما من الحقيقه يبدو بان هذا الكلام
ياتي في هذا السياق في هذه المرحله على
الاقل حتى الان بينما التحقيقات لا تزال
مستمره فيما يخص هجوم اصفهان شكلا ومضمونا
شكرا لك عبد القادر فايز مدير مكتب
الجزيره من طهران شكرا لك